so was geht hier vor max und herzlich
willkommen zum heutigen video wir
spielen la cruz zusammen mit kia hey es
ist lucky borst wie gesagt dass es so
ziemlich lucky star wars auf dem server
von doktor becks der ganz neu aufgemacht
hat wir testen das ganz einfach mal aus
und ich habe zwar einen schneemann
rausbekommen auf jeden fall sehr viel
glück
aus dem lucky dog bekommt ok wack waka
waka waka und bilder sowie ein
bischofsamt ja bisher nur provision an
die gal ich geh jetzt einmal die mitte
justin ich werde auch ich muss sagen ich
habe noch nichts verloren man einblicke
wie blöcke zum bauen
ich vermute mal mehr brauchen die
erschwert entweder aus den kisten oder
du musst du dir tatsächlich abbauen und
fleißig habe direkten lakies ort
schärfer haltbarkeit verbrennung
gründung richtige pvp da kommt ein
gegner ich will keinen block mehr und
hat nur ein schwert jetzt bekommen und
schuhe männlichen 100 erledigt der
minister dann
du willst du denn ich will ich bin schon
die bitte ich habe das amt gab aber ich
habe mit auch ganz gut an der control
solche gibt es keinen blick oft gar
keine
ich weiß nicht ich müsste mir jetzt holz
abbauen wieder aus dem holz spitzhacke
machen dann daraus halt immer so weiter
hast du nicht zu einem fliege ich habe
nur ein schwert aus gekommen und wollten
leute auch aus dem normalen kisten aus
den kissen aber gar nichts drin ja gut
dann komm ich habe erstens solier oder
ja bitte
ich habe mich aber nicht ein paar blöcke
wo willst du noch mal bei uns auf der
insel wo auf der seite wohl aber in der
mitte ist da rechts daneben
ich sehe ich kann nicht ganz an rannten
ja jetzt für mich war perfekt dafür
perfekt dann komme ich einfach über die
insel wahrscheinlich schnell zu sein gab
schon einiges gemacht heute ich find der
spielmodus das echt komisch ich glaube
du hast einfach pech also ich hab drei
halbes textblöcke komisch ich brauche
was essen und blicke ich habe erstmal
blöcke ich habe einige alles ja hier
schon mal warten kann ich mir noch kurz
und einen bogen alter view bogen ins
chaos echt mal ist kannst du es kannst
aber kann er auch das noch bevor der
täter kommt weil ich weil ich weil ich
ja ja ist der wäsche
ich habe eine mail bekommen war trainer
kommt hat ein problem allerdings knapp
marc schneeberger fakten eis das war es
dann aber zu diese sind auch deine du
tötest du die ganze zeit gewartet
bei mir mit notebook machen du rennst
drauf und ich verberge 321 kopf das
waren explodierende bogen oh mein gott
auf dem zwölf hektar angriffig mehr
angriffen von den hunden unterwegs
ich habe das nicht mehr das lakies bis
zum kreis junger wir haben echt gutes
zeichen wäre doch gelacht hat es mir
noch vielleicht passt wie manche packen
okay geben wir direkt vor meinen wir
haben nämlich auch nicht genau zwei
andere spieler diesen aber aus einem
anderen team vielleicht ich glaube leute
wir wägen für die erste runde läuft
demnach stabil bei 6 3 sie ist ja noch
relativ gut
die abgänger noch eine dran ja ähnlich
wie der prämie von dr vom server ohne
davon ist auf einer matte und verdammt
ist abgelaufen
drei stücken ach nee das ist ja ist ja
auch eine explosion zu tun dass man von
hier oder geht es
ich dachte okay bogen ist okay da komme
nicht ganz hin aber ich denke so dürfen
wir vorkommen wo er wird aufgaben alter
der andere typ hat auch ein explosions
punkten ich freue mich sehr über hier
sagt ein ziemlich alter aprimo es
probiert es hat aber wenig getötet
leider bernd pawlak
ich komm ich komm ich habe auch noch 15
stück werden die lange 15
dann verändert sich eher noch so 25 aber
ich glaube nein ich bin wegen dem bug
gestorben
ich bin einfach wegen dem bug gestorben
es war nicht vom server verschuldet
sondern ich habe einfach den block unter
mir platzierten ist wieder verschwunden
also richtig ärgerlich kontrast ich
hatte so gutes equipment martin
schneebälle aus schade schade dass egal
wie du deinen nächsten runde wieder was
für die alter so leute wir sind auf der
nächsten karte runde 2 beginnt bei mango
leisten anfang die schutzzeit über das
meer von what the [ __ ] alter der ist
einfach ein gentges port direkt neben
mir zum glück ist er in einem blog drink
responsibly lakic 8 und martin simma
spiel perfekt alter junge und ich ein
bisschen schiss dass der dass der
scheint irgendwie freikommt enorm
erschwert probieren unterzukriegen kommt
schon probiert den giants ok ich hab'
den wein und andere sieht nicht dass wir
das komische herzen hier kriegt aus
einem leck über kriegs ein extraheft das
echt nice die ganze ich bei ihm ist auch
in berlin scheint gespannt wie ist eine
nun ja er hat evelyn tibetischer
wiederum koste alter kohleblöcke ab und
braucht auch dringend essen du hast ja
auch ganz abgesagt
dann sollten wir uns auf jeden fall
schnellen gegner verknüpfen und nicht
mehr sprinten dass wir das ohne war habe
ich schon
er hat nur noch fünf herzen ich habe
noch 10
aber das ist ja schon mal gemacht gehen
wir einfach mal vor zu der insel
haltungen augen nach hinten gerne mal
weiter willst du mich vielleicht die
größte in halberstadt nicht so viel gold
lassen
er verdankt ihm auch schon als sehr
junge leute ja das wird jetzt echt noch
blöcke dafür brambauer mit treppen
ich hab keine rolle
ärgerlich dass dort kicken wegen wieder
hinten
also ich muss von spiel bekommen
wahrscheinlich weit gesprungen ist
verdammt alt wollen ausprobieren
eine letzte runde machen wir noch leute
nächste karte abbauen ohne 1 dass man
den willen der regierung lag ihm
irgendwie das anscheinend datenbank dass
die kisten nicht befüllt werden
und da ist was drin ich hab schon ich
habe schon erlebt dass sachen drin sind
aber okay das nennt man sollte
vielleicht vorsichtig sein
das mal mit ab in die mitte ab in den
urlaub ab in den urlaub.de zoll 480 kg
schwarz ich kann nicht nehmen scheint
schon wieder mitte aber ich habe ihn
runter gekickt 234 okay ist mein angel
verdammt investors bekommt so ich komme
auch in die mitte passt schon alles
geholt
diese noch nicht noch mehr hunde für
mich die alle sterben leider ein extra
herzfeld so gut mit jeder fall
ich habe noch gar keine gar keine
rüstung also ich bin für alles dankbar
was du mir geben kannst du bist du denn
jetzt legt euch alte neues klavier
rüstung
aber ok dann lasst videoblog abbauen
oder so ich mag für erfahrungen
den kanal haben mit erfolgen von denen
eigentlich oder genetische orthopädische
und portugal auf
danke wenn der band an einen tag sein
eigenes leid erfährt dann weiß ich und
buch von ihr so was macht wird nicht ist
es aber was du bist echt fertig hast du
auch nachher gibt es doch nicht
danke der kollege ist ein schneebrett
ich hoffe es hat euch trotzdem gefallen
und wir sehen zwar nicht mal wieder
mach's gut bis dann